au stop lay a qu'une bouchée de caries
[Musique]
je suis ni la première fois au festival
de cannes pour radio nova et en est et
jean françois bizot avait réussi notre
seulement une petite radio je sais pas
comment il avait combiné ça c'était un
roi des combines comme ça on était sur
une terrasse du martinez et ont erré en
leur faisant croire qu'on faisait que
l'émission est en fête le soir ont gardé
les passions retourner dormir mais
beaucoup plus nombreux que prévu non ou
dans les parterres dans la chambre il ya
des gens dans la baignoire
tout le monde se retrouve au petit
majestic et rezé le monde toute la nuit
j'ai connu le gymnase de caunes qui
mitraillant la facette du martinez des
grandes arrivées de caunes c'était
incroyable d'arriver de conçu à
croisette et jean nador est donc ils
fendent elle est refoulée josé garcia
dans des numéros vraiment c'était une
impression c'est des canulars de gamme
interne aval quoi mes clients suite à
mes émissions michel denisot qui avaient
ce calme et cette douceur rester et
c'est très agréable d'être reçus par lui
j'ai eu un trou parce qu'en fait je me
tais
en fait beaucoup de gens en direct et à
une vision vous demande de mettre une
oreillette parce que le réalisateur a
peur qu'on parte en live et qu'on
panique et qu'on dise n'importe quoi
donc je ne suis pas le faire et j'ai eu
vraiment un trou et là normalement le
réalisateur dit là tu dois dire quelque
chose et
et donc je suis dit j'ai dit excusez moi
une seconde j'ai un trou j'ai pas dire
le soin seconde je vois bien je suis
allé en coulisse demander ce qu'ils
veulent c'est faire ce qui est personnes
en coulisses donc je suis revenu et par
miracle à personne il fallait juste que
le dise alors qui a gagné la personne
attendait cette phrase a hélas elle a
enchaîné ils l ont cru que c'était une
blague minable d'un acteur français je
déteste monter les marches
parce que je pense que c'est amusant si
on est là mais debbouze ou alain delon
ou si tout à coup c'est le rêve d'enfant
de quelqu'un mais entre les deux ans
devant tout ce qu'on fait là et puis si
on ne sait pas vraiment faire des arrêts
photo pour mm comme ça on est
complètement
il ya une et c'est toujours de me
débrouiller pour passer par derrière
lors d'un photocall ce n'était pas la
montée des marches et juste un arrêt
devant 700 photographe qui si vous
connaissez très bien sont chantés mur le
vote non il ya quelques branches et des
haches comprend si vous connaissent
moins à l'idée
toi et puis si nous et roscoe play et
accueille blanchette qui arrive
[Musique]